on démarre d'être arrêté avec cette
surprenante histoire oui alors attention
là nous allons voir du côté de bourdin
direct sur rmc découverte et on a appris
que le directeur de l'enseignement
catholique de nantes avait été mise en
examen pour tenez vous bien trafic de
stupéfiants à nantes le directeur de
l'enseignement catholique était aussi
dit leur ouïe suspecté d'avoir en
consommer partage et de grosses
quantités de drogue dont de la cocaïne
lors de soirées il aurait fait profiter
à d'autres personnes de ces drogues
c'est un père de famille 52 ans qui a
été nommé directeur à nantes fin 2017
il est mis en examen pour trafic de
stupéfiants il a été licencié au 6 mai
pour motif professionnel qui a priori
n'ont rien à voir avec cette affaire la
perquisition de son domicile n'a pour
l'instant rien donné
alors on l'a dit vous avez entendu il il
aurait été licencié de son poste pour je
sais des motifs et des raisons
professionnelles qui n'ont pas de lien
juridique avec cette mise en examen se
demande tout ça peut être d'autre des
raisons professionnelles qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ça pour un licenciement ce
ca cerise sur le gâteau on sait pas ce
qu'il se passe c'est un père de famille
il a 52 ans on a de quoi tout de même
être un petit peu étonné francesca c'est
archi flippant c'est évidemment
scandaleux dans n'importe quel
établissement mais d'autant plus dans un
établissement privé parce que quand tu
essayes de l'investir pour que ton
enfant est dans un établissement privé
c'est généralement un sacrifice oui donc
tu as envie d'avoir en plus un directeur
qui soit quand même correct voire très
très bien alors moi je ne comprends pas
qu'ils aient pas des enquêtes avait
récemment qu'on mène des enquêtes
le personnel éducateur inbal entendu des
enquêtes menées par qui avait même passé
par l'éducation nationale par la police
abat parking par la police carrément
quant à moi je suis désolé je confie mon
enfant dans une école alors qu'elles
soient publiques ou qu'elles soient
privées ou catholiques ou autre j'ai
quand même envie d'avoir des garanties
on en fait ce risque c'est la
présentation d'informations qui pose un
problème justement ont fait exprès de te
dire directeur d'une institution
catholique style on a fait un truc
sacralisé on ne met à côté professeur
cocaïne et là tout de suite toi tu bug
en réalité il n'est pas viré pour la
cocaïne il est viré pour autre chose
attendez attendez la consommation de
cocaïne elle n'est pas réservée juste à
des gens qui ont des métiers pourri où
ils font des métiers et qui sont pas
relations avec les autres elle est
partout et les familles tout justement
dans les milieux les bobos dit on ne
sait pas si les consommateurs contre
amiens caen était aussi n'est que entre
10 mai consommateurs il est malade et
les occasions nafila ses élèves ok je
suis d'accord faut il faire autrement
c'est la technique je suis désolé tu
fustige les médias en disant on l'a
présenté comme ça je suis désolé c'est
exact de will et les directeurs de
l'enseignement catholique
moi ce qui m'énerve dans cette histoire
est profondément et ça nous blesse c'est
que cette histoire j'en ai entendu
parler nulle part outre que chez bourdin
ç'aurait été dans un lycée du 9 3 par
exemple noura sigma tease et aurait
essuyé un scandale national
et ça ça m'énerve votre fils il est
scolarisé en école privée en école
privée
maintenant je pense que évidemment c'est
un vrai sacrifice de mettre nos enfants
dans des écoles privées donc tu as envie
qu'il soit d'autant plus irréprochable
mais par contre moi je suis pas d'accord
avec ce que tu as testé la voiture s'il
est simplement consommateur s'il n'est
même pas trafiquant mais je m'excuse
il ya quand même normal dans des zep en
plein d'ennemis j'ai pas envie d'avoir
comme que le directeur de mon fils si
près mais admettons vingtaine d'années
et est tanné on parle toujours de la
cocaïne dans le milieu du showbiz mais
je peux tout est là pour avoir travaillé
dans une clinique des addictions que la
cocaïne aller chez les banquiers qu'on a
eu des ambassadeurs qui ont accepté
votre compte en banque afin que ces
moyens royan d'allemand non mais vous
vous a laissé l'impression tout de même
que vous mettez un gros bémol en taisant
ses balises est grave oui parce qu'on a
fait de l'information sensationnel en
présentant l'institution catholique dont
il est le directeur
il est viré pour des causes
professionnelles seront c'est un mauvais
directeur d'école et ont dit les
trafiquants de drogue mais on a relié
tout de suite les deux c'est pas bien
mais ça ne sent pas à ce qu'aulas pardon
parce que francesca emilie qui joue les
fiers les vierges effarouchées se trouve
ça au nom vestiaires même si c'est un
petit peu mais moi je comprends tout à
fait aujourd'hui il faut vous comprenez
la rue mais ce directeur d'école et
c'est sa vie privée un moment donné il
ya une perquisition il n'y a rien eu
mais attendez en train de lui faire un
procès on ne connaît pas sa ville
attendait en effet ménard mais pour vous
ça ne peut ça ne poserait pas de souci
que le directeur d'une école soit
consommateur de l'an l'occurrence les
consommateurs mais qui sur ce plateau
n'ai jamais pris de drogue jamais
soixantaine en partie dans le public je
suis sûr que dans le public
rien n'a beaucoup parce que la meilleure
ici et là peut pas vous laisser dire et
tout le monde consomme delà de la drogue
on va vous laisser dire que c'est
quelque chose de banal on va vous
laisser dire que c'est quelque chose de
pas grave
attention aux mots d'abord ya des
enfants qui ne regarde pas ce que ces
sont les vacances scolaires c'est très
dangereux ce n'est pas quelqu'un acte
banal ce n'est pas comme je sais pas
prendre un carré de chocolat où aller
c'est qu'ils ont voulu faire le bouc
émissaire de cette personne est un
consommateur
ces deux faces est fait de façon festive
et on en fait un dealer et rendez vous
compte pour un homme
on entrerait en lice dans sa tâche il en
est si là on est en train de faire un
dealer alors qu'on est en train de
briser sa vie pour peut-être une soirée
un peu arrosée où quelque chose et c'est
arrivé c'est là que je veux dire que
c'est arrivé à beaucoup de gens et là
lui il porte le chapeau mais c'est
complètement fou de défendre à ce point
là ce mec là parce que tu n'en sais rien
en plus tu sais pas si les trafiquants
simplement consommateur mais toi la
place imagine que tes parents demain est
ce que tu as envie que le corps
enseignant prennent de la drogue ou
trafic de la drogue là on touche quand
même au sacré c'est ton enfance jeudi
rang c'est pas comme si tu parles de de
cabano là tu parles débat demandé l'avis
de nos téléspectateurs ce qu'il pense
sur cette nouvelle ce directeur
d'enseignement catholique de nantes qui
a été mise en examen pour l'heure été
mises en examen pour trafic impact
simplement pour consommation
quand même la faire dira s'il n'est que
si les trafiquants ou simplement entre
guillemets simplement un consommateur
dites nous ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag sécurité on est très curieux de
savoir quel est votre sentiment sur
cette affaire est ce que comme ces
messieurs vous dit après tout on ne sait
pas et puis il n'est que peut-être
consommateurs et ce n'est pas voilà
enfin un bon 6 comme les les jeunes
femmes sur le plateau où vous êtes
horrifiée parce que franz qui avait
horrifié en bas